si no fuera por las sirenas de ataque
aéreo algunas calles de bach mod podrían
llegar a tener un aire veraniego y
alegre las banderas ucranianas siguen
ondeando aquí en una de las pocas
ciudades del donbass que no está bajo
control ruso pero también hay muchos
signos de guerra un estadio de atletismo
bombardeado con las gradas reventadas
humo ondeando desde las casas destruidas
y trozos de metralla en las calles
el frente no está lejos y los residentes
de bach muta lo saben se están
preparando para una nueva ofensiva
masiva rusa después de la creciente
concentración de sus tropas en la zona
y nunca pensé que habría una guerra así
entre rusia y ucrania y toda la gente
normal tiene miedo es natural que otra
cosa podemos hacer
al fin y al cabo nadie está a salvo
pueden caer bombas y te pueden matarlo
emprendiendo un peligroso viaje hacia el
centro de ucrania en autobuses al menos
un tercio de la población ya ha huido
hace dos semanas entre 10 y 15 personas
se evacuaban diariamente ahora el número
se ha duplicado tras hacerse con la
provincia de lugansk vladimir putin ha
centrado sus esfuerzos en la de donges
el control de ambas dejaría toda la
región del donbass en manos de moscú se
espera a que el siguiente paso sea back
move clave por su estratégica carretera
hacia cama torch uno de los centros
administrativos del donbass pero tras su
victoria contra las tropas rusas y los
separatistas en la zona durante los
primeros meses de la guerra los soldados
ucranianos han prometido luchar con uñas
y dientes para mantener el este de
ucrania